[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video david und ich hab mich heute ein
ganz kleines bisschen schicker gemacht
und bin ich ja auch schon immer sehr
schick aber heute habe ich mir gedacht
alex nächste noch mal einen drauf
das heutige video entsteht in corporate
ich hoffe der kräftig wie ich jetzt
nicht zu sehr
falls ja ignoriert das einfach auf jeden
fall entweder das heutige video in
kooperation mit ca und ich habe mir was
ganz besonderes überlegt und
wahrscheinlich am titel oben und
institute
wer trägt einen titel nach unten ihr
habt ihr wahrscheinlich umfang lesen und
wage es heute um viel zeit vom abschluss
bei gegangen die ihn kennen bevor wir
allerdings loslegen wenn ich es werde
nervös eine richtig coole sache mit zwei
und war erstmal bleibt auf jeden fall
bis zum ende dran weil dann könnt ihr
wirklich was mega vettels gewinn
zusammen mit schülern oder so am 25 02
2010 mit zwei wochen darf ich im c store
in oberhausen im zelt wurde das soll ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich jedem was sagen wer
da in der fdj und auf jeden fall alle
vorbei ich darf doch ein kleines meet
and greet veranstalten ein richtiger
freund nicht mehr so viele die mich
vergleich zu treffen kommt er vorbei und
was sie da am ende auch noch machen
können das erzähle ich am ende des
videos
aber das wollen jetzt erstmal los dass
zuschauer kannten geht um 15 toren geht
die ursprünglich bis 17 uhr aber wenn
ich gleich alle geschafft habe dann
mache ich natürlich auch noch länger
meisten bürger bin drei uhr am nächsten
morgen also kommt auf jeden fall bei us
talk ist ob ich würde sagen bei 13.000
gleich zum nächsten bad von zehn teil
von irgendwas ihr könnt ja meinen
kommentar steinbach jetzt will ich gar
nicht lange lagern und viel spaß mit typ
let go
[Musik]
alex lowes companies sowie
bayernligamannschaft euch das keine lust
heute ehrlich dank aber ich hab echt
keine lust mir der langweiler
[Musik]
ich komme wieder kommt oft einfach in
jogginghose ich probiere heute den
abschluss der verzweifelte aufreißer
nicht gemessen
das weiß ich auch nicht der nicht
anwesend
[Musik]
geil
der bunte vogel
[Musik]
werde ein bisschen zu viel getrunken hat
auch hier du das machst du nicht
rasselte 112 108 frauen aber naja ich
bin ja trotzdem der beste schüler
gewesen
ich wollte halt nicht dass die anderen
traurig bin bei 0,8 und dann
[Musik]
die zehn typen und jetzt darf ich auch
mal was cooles verkünden denn richtig
gutes gewinnspiel und ich würd mal sagen
wenn ihr eure mitschüler richtigkeit auf
oder eure schule ist es gar nicht nur
unwahrscheinlich dass wieder den
hauptgewinn abräumt
deswegen passt gut in meinem video clips
abschlussball und ihr könnt praktisch
auf was in die richtung machen ist glaub
ich verkünde erstmal die breite und war
der erste preis ist mit 15.000 euro für
ihre abi kasse oder einfach für eure
stufen karte der zweite preis ist peter
euro und der dritte preis 500 euro
was tun was ihr dafür tun wird ist
eigentlich ganz einfach und war ihr
müsst in irgend einer filiale bei euch
um die ecke gehen
einfach reingehen heißt wenn ein teil
oder so dann sucht ihr euch euer fasnet
abschlussball ausweist jetzt für die
jungs anzug sowie echte landwirt oder
für die mädchen im kleid so wie es meine
freundin an hatte sich damit schnell vor
der c&a foto waren fotografieren und
damit ist dann auch cas party.de hoch
und dann habt ihr eigentlich schon
mitgemacht ja auch jeder hüpfen auf holz
den link bestätigen dass ihr sechster
mitgemacht habt in eurem e mail und die
schule und die meisten leute mitgemacht
haben als wenn wirklich sehr viele
feiern mit schülern an der aktion
teilgenommen haben
dann habt ihr nicht helfen sie sonst
auch die 15.000 euro und ich bin 15 auf
eurem entlastend wirkt das läuft auf
jeden fall ab touren dafür vielleicht
auch ganz cool
er könnte zum 8 an diesem zweiten also
bis zum ende dieser aktion wenn ihr als
sagte ja ich kaufe mir bei den anzug
oder das kleid könnt ihr einfach mit der
zeit meint euro oder einfach nur auch
künftig thema hat dann könnt ihr die
besitzende zufolge ein oder gleich an
sollten fünf an dieser zweite ac n a
oberhausen sid greet mit mir zu schlafen
ich freue mich auf euch an ich bin
gespannt werden wir können alle zusammen
keine flotten machen und ansonsten
lassen nach oben damit mich sehr freuen
und schreibt auch einfach in die
kommentare
welcher typ euch am meisten gefallen
oder welcher tier zu sein
darauf bin ich gespannt und jede fahrt
fort wir sehen uns
am montag wieder bis deine